prit has done a lot of praying recently
this time last year he set out to take a
well-paid IT job in
Myanmar but when his plane touched down
in Yangon he was bundled into a car and
driven across the country to
Lai he was held in a compound known as
building nine with hundreds of others
from around the world armed guards on
the
gate held in prison-like dorms they were
forced to run scams from formulas worked
out by the gang crypto stocks and
romance one I was told to reach out to
people or whom they call clients online
I was told to flirt with them gain their
trust and affections and get them to
invest their money into scam one of
their victims lost more than
$80,000 but the scammers had no choice
if you didn't do it you will punish
baton elect uted and locked up you have
no choice what to do
it phones recovered from the gang
members show the injuries they
inflicted if someone found out that you
reach out to the outside world for help
you might get
killed s porn wants to keep her identity
hidden she was 3 months pregnant when
she was tricked into going to Myanmar to
make some money for her new arrival she
was held for 3 months before being
rescued
I was afraid I heard the sound of people
being electrocuted when I hung out near
the football pitch I wondered if he
could receive the same kind of
punishment but her greatest fear was
what would happen if the gang found out
about the baby growing inside
her my roommate told me that if the boss
found out about any pregnant woman the
baby would be aborted
her daughter's now 3 months old named
pay New Year to Mark the holiday when
she got
home these are the fortunate ones the
United Nations estimated last year that
12,000 people were trapped in scam
centers in Myanmar in a country that's
Lawless
divided and in the grip of Civil War
here in tajil they've just arrested 500
Chinese Nationals on suspicion of
setting up new scam centers and that's
the real concern although they've closed
down some of the big operations that the
operators will just pack up and move
elsewhere Tony Chang Al jazer on the Tha
Myanmar
border make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaer